salut c'est que ce gros il ya quelques
années microsoft s'est bien plantée dans
l'univers du smartphone
ils vont essayer de revenir en force
mais avec un produit qui va être pas
réellement un smartphone un hybride
peut-être une révolution est ce qu'ils
vont réussir c'est pas gagné d'avancé
mais ça peut le faire on va essayer dé
quitter sa et notamment à travers un
email capitaine face à je l'espère tout
de suite on y va maintenant
l'info nous vient du site the verge qui
a révélé l'intercepteur sais pas quelle
manière est ce qu ils l'ont attrapé
intercepté un email interne à microsoft
qui parle effectivement de ce smartphone
fa smartphone c'est pas vraiment un
smartphone c'est un hybride entre une
tablette un carnet de notes un
smartphone un ordinateur c'est un
produit qui selon microsoft en tout cas
pour être vraiment révolutionnaire et
changer un peu la donne sur le marché du
smartphone qui aujourd'hui malgré
quelques évolutions techniques
un petit peu linéaire on a un petit peu
tout vu on a des écrans plus grands des
plus grandes diagonales
on a des petits tiroirs qui servent pour
faire les photos il ya pas mal
d'évolutions on devrait avoir des écrans
pliables qui pourrait aussi être une
révolution d'une autre manière
mais pour l'instant ce qu'on voit si
intéressant c'est toujours plus
puissants sachant pas bien peu
l'histoire est là effectivement avec ce
produit ça pourrait changer l'histoire
et ça pourrait permettre à microsoft de
revenir vraiment dans le jeu avec un
produit beaucoup plus puissant beaucoup
plus performant équipe au coup très
novateur il faut connaître quelques
années microsoft c'est quand même bien
bien bien bien casser la gueule et a
loupé complètement le virage des
smartphones
autant ils sont excellents sur les
ordinateurs sur les contreforts plein
d'autres produits sur du logiciel sur du
hardware
ils ont vraiment un écosystème qui est
extrêmement complet mais il leur manque
et c'est vraiment dommage pour une
marque microsoft la partie téléphonie
mobile avec le projet de remèdes à ils
vont revenir un peu dans le game c'est
ce qu'on va essayer de voir en tout cas
ce projet arrive vraiment à point nommé
ça fait deux ans priori que microsoft
travaille dessus
pas un 2018 début 2019 pourrait voir
arriver une ouvert pour les smartphones
l'arrivée des écrans pliables le samsung
galaxy x début 2019 peut-être un
smartphone pliable côté de chez huawei
fin d'année voici voir un peu ça de très
près donc
abonnez-vous on reste connectés et ce
fameux projet andromeda du côté
microsoft vous en avait déjà parlé il ya
quelques mois déjà fait une vidéo pour
vous parler du projet andromeda de ce
qu'il devait être effectivement une
nouvelle info qui a été publiée par deux
verges
sani mail interne à microsoft ils n'ont
pas du tout publié par contre nous
révéler le contenu en tout cas une bonne
partie est une partie qui restaient
confidentiels
ce produit prendraient donc la forme
d'une tablette pliable un petit peu
comme surface format poche et d'ailleurs
des brevets déposés par microsoft qui
montre ce à quoi pourrait ressembler la
bête le designer david breier s'est
d'ailleurs inspiré des brevets pour
essayer de faire une représentation qui
somme toute pourrait être assez fidèle à
ce que microsoft pourrait faire de ce
produit au niveau
deux écrans centraux alors deux écrans
ou un écran pliable
ça reste un petit peu le point
d'interrogation tout de suite une
charnière permet de les réunir alors
n'aura pas la charniére semble que les
deux écrans sont vraiment côte à côte
une charnière au dos on devrait avoir un
écran en façade et de l'autre côté 1,2
unis sans écran on pourrait donc le
plier dans un sens et dans l'autre un
petit peu cette manière là vous auriez
donc ici un écran au dos rien vous
pourriez l'ouvrir avoir un seul grand
écran leur piller comme ça vous pourriez
le poser comme ça avoir deux écrans
pourquoi pas le maître comme ça imaginez
un clavier là et un écran on pourrait en
gros l'utiliser comme un ordinateur
comme une tablette en double écran en
pause il y avait qu un seul mais mes
grands écrans pour pouvoir travailler
pourquoi pas imiter des images
travaillées
on peut imaginer pas mal de chose rare
dans ce sens et ça pourrait être
vraiment très intéressant alors la
question que je me pose c'est au trépas
qui pourrait faire doublon par rapport à
ce que pourrait proposer samsung et son
galaxy x c'est-à-dire un seul même et
grand écran est ce que ça serait un
produit un peu trop similaires voici a
contrario microsoft
on est vraiment senti l'air du temps et
travaillerez sur des projets
sensiblement similaires à ceux de
samsung ça à l'avenir nos liens ce
serait donc un produit capable d'effacer
les différences entre l'informatique et
la téléphonie mobile serait un outil un
peu passe partout qui pourrait convenir
aussi bien pour travailler pour des
étudiants pour des professionnels sur un
petit format pocket qu'on pourrait
emmener partout lors des déplacements
qu'on n'est pas besoin de sortir un
ordinateur ou une grande table est à
chaque fois on pourrait complètement
l'utiliser pour bosser on aura aussi un
usage un peu plus ludique
on pourrait imaginer des jeux sur un
grand écran un peu comme ça on a déjà
parlé pour le samsung galaxy x c'est un
produit qui pourrait être sensiblement
similaire mais à la sauce microsoft
sauf que celui ci à la différence de
samsung galaxy x aurait un stylet et
c'est là dessus que pour sr l'aspect un
peu plus professionnel
on imagine facilement comme je le disais
que un des deux écrans on pourrait s'en
sort mais en clavier on aurait donc un
clavier virtuel un stylet on aurait donc
à la fois un ordinateur portable est à
la fois un téléphone est à la fois une
grande tablette
cet email n'ont donc que c'est bien un
projet que microsoft a dans les tuyaux
par contre rien n'est sûr quant à une
date de sortie est ce qu'ils vont le
sortir oui ou non
est-ce qu'ils travaillent dessus est ce
que c'est un proto qui leur servira
créer un autre produit est ce qu'ils
vont attendre un petit peu de voir ce
que va proposer la concurrence est ce
qu'ils vont voir un petit peu
l'accueil réservé au samsung galaxy x
est ce qu'ils vont voir la copie la
concurrence pour ensuite raffiné la leur
monde dans l'adn de microsoft il ya
plein interrogations qui planent quant à
la sortie de ce produit j'imagine que
microsoft a vraiment joué la sécurité
ils sont déjà bien implantés au niveau
de la téléphonie mobile des quelques
années là l'idée pour eux c'est de faire
un retour victorieux il faut vraiment
pas se tromper au niveau de la copie de
sortir un produit très intéressant qui
va vraiment correspondre à des attentes
et pas seulement un produit similaire à
d'autres il faut vraiment un produit
exceptionnel qui ne ressemble à aucun
autre
là où microsoft pourrait faire très fort
ces coupes un petit peu l'herbe sous le
pied à samsung c'est pourquoi pas à ce
moment là le sortir plus tôt que samsung
le sortir fin 2018 ce qui serait
extrêmement fort le signe très fort qui
leur permettraient de réussir d'abord un
seul même grand écran pliable un produit
hybride entre samsung galaxy note 9 avec
un stylet nouvelle génération entre un
samsung galaxy x là ça pourrait vraiment
avoir un sens mais une fois de plus il
faut arrêter avec un produit une
meilleure que les concurrents et surtout
bien plus tôt que reste maintenant à
savoir si les consommateurs si vous six
mois si on sera réceptif à cette
typologie de produits
on en parle depuis quelques temps parce
que je veux c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'intéressant autant avec le samsung
galaxy x hauteur avec des écrans
pliables d'iphone qui pourrait arriver
dans plusieurs années autant des
smartphones pliable du côté de chez
huawei c'est très intéressant parce que
pas même un petit peu de sentir ce qui
va arriver et de voir si le consommateur
est prêt oui ou non je pourrais me
sentir prêt ça dépend du tarif accident
avec une solution qui coûte 1500 2000
euros ça a tout dit être rédhibitoire et
compliqué si par contre sur des
smartphones abordables abordables sur
une solution comme ça jeudi entre 800
900 max milo rau why not ça peut être
intéressant et ça peut toucher beaucoup
de monde
maintenant à voir en terme d' usage à
voir en termes de prise en main à voir
en terme de fabrication si ces produits
seront intéressants oui entre
prétendants se trouve très intéressant
c'est la volonté de ces constructeurs de
dire bon ok on s'est planté maintenant
on va révolutionner marché on va arriver
d'une autre manière
on va s'appuyer sur les bases solides
pour microsoft c'est la gamme surface on
va s'appuyer sur le côté logiciel
derrière avec windows avec tout tout
tout tout tout le système et tout
l'écosystème qu'ils ont d'un point de
vue logiciel microsoft signé dans
machine vous avez du hardware et du
software là ne peuvent pas se planter
reste à voir si ça peut vous intéresse
d'ailleurs dit moi vous en commentaire
ce que vous en pensez est ce que vous
pourriez vous tenter par un surface
phone un projet andromeda dites moi en
basse que vous en pensez surtout
- ce que vous attendez est ce qui
pourrait vous intéresser comme
caractéristiques techniques mark et moi
tout ça en bas on en discute d'ici là on
reste connectés jeu vite comme
d'habitude mdc des jolies pousse à vous
abonner on reste connectés et mark et
moi tout ce que vous voulez inspiration
questions suggestions directement en bas
en commentaire d'ici là son ex je vous
embrasse
et n'oubliez pas vous êtes les meilleurs
ciao
[Musique]